Thanks Prasad so I moved the rancor
Gregg Asian part a little bit towards
the end of the title indicating that I
will mostly focus on correlation
clustering and since this is a big data
workshop I will also try to bring in
some data and hence the subdued emphasis
on rank aggregation and this is joint
work with a few of my collaborators a
postdoc Greg Pouliot Amin Ahmad and our
bio resident bio expert janma so what is
the interest or the idea behind this
talk very recently you have observed
that there has been quite a lot of
interest in community detection and
different people or different research
groups called different problems
community detection problems but you can
think of community detection problems is
basically arising in the study of social
structures or social networks where
basically the idea is to identify
tight-knit communities by defining a
community in terms of the density of
connectivity of entities in the group or
people in the group and here is an
example a very clear example of a Kurata
Club graph where you have notes that
indicate people members of the club and
then two different types of communities
and it's clear from the picture that red
and blue form different communities
because of the density of the
connectivity between identities other
areas where community detection has made
appearance is in bioinformatics we all
have some vague understanding that there
are communities of interacting entities
that are called genes that are jointly
responsible for governing or controlling
some function in the cell and in the
last 10 years or so there was a lot of
interest in terms of trying to find
communities that are related in terms of
either similarity or function or related
in terms of similarity of sequence or
some other property but another
community that you may have seen quite
frequently is collaborative communities
in mathematics and this is a very nice
drawing that Ron gray I made as a
tribute to her - who is a very centrally
focused entity in this community so what
our interest in the thing that motivated
our work is a new paradigm which we call
community detection functional community
detection in is particularly in cancer
genomics and it's a very interesting new
paradigm because it defines community in
a very non-standard way and let me
really quickly explain to you what is a
community or a what we would call from
now on a pathway in a cancer cell so
what happens in the progression and
onset of cancer is basically that
certain genes get mutated or replicated
so you have different copies a copy
number of the genes so for simplicity
let's just assume the genes get mutated
there is an uncanny ability that cancer
has that it targets only genes in
certain pathways or modules in order to
preserve energy and basically the idea
is if it can mutate one gene which is
crucial for one module it doesn't have
to touch the other genes and then what
happens is you would see modules where
only one gene is mutated and hence you
basically strike out one key player in a
community you attack a member of the
community you take out the whole
community so you don't have to really
attack multiple members of the community
to disrupt the pathway so this is what
recently came to be known in the bio
community as the so-called mutual
exclusivity principle and it says that
when you look at the real data at most
one mutation or cure spare driver
pathway in cancer another thing that was
observed is that cancer tends to attack
a certain number of pathways and it's
important that all these pathways are
covered which means in the majority of
patients you will see the same modules
attacked maybe in potentially different
ways by attacking different genes but
you will have this coverage property as
well and the third thing that biologists
notice is that the modules that are
attacked are usually fairly small and
this is what we call bounded pathway
size problem or a pathway limitation to
include let's say everywhere anywhere
between 6 and 15 genes that's true for
most pathways but not for all so the
question is when they were approached by
some people that work in these on these
problems how do we actually dent
these functional pathways by using
methods from community detection and the
first thing that came to mind when we
saw the problem is to invoke ideas that
have been around in the computer science
community for almost 15 years and it's a
work that was known under the name of
correlation clustering which may be a
little bit misleading but in general its
refers to a set of techniques that are
concerned with optimization on graphs so
correlation clustering was introduced by
Bansal bloom and Chawla and it's in its
most elementary plain-vanilla
formulation it says that you're given n
objects you can view them as nodes in a
graph and for some of these objects you
give a judgement or an assessment of how
similar or dissimilar the objects are so
for example here you have a graph and
you objects that are similar are
connected by blue edges those that are
dissimilar by orange edges so we can
assume that the color of the edges
indicates A+ remind - or infinity or
this a similarity or dissimilarity and
the question now the problem of interest
is partition the vertices into clusters
or community so that you minimize the
number of positive or blue edges going
between communities or clusters and at
the same time minimize the number of
negative edges or disagreeing entities
or dissimilar entities within clusters
so this is an obvious solution for this
problem you will just put two by two and
then one vertex here because you only
have blue edges within clusters orange
edges between clusters and unfortunately
these three edges also go between
clusters so this is what is plain
vanilla correlation clustering and it's
a correlation clustering is an
optimization on graph kind of problem
but it's also some form of agnostic
learning because we were never told in
advance what the number of communities
is which is very important for bio
related problems and it's related to a
host of very interesting questions which
deal with optimization on graphs such as
graph partition of balance graph
partition and edge partitioning rank
aggregation which was supposed to be the
second topic in this talk I'll comment
on it
a little bit later towards the end of
the presentation so what is known about
this correlation clustering and what are
the basic results we had so far finding
the best clustering is obviously np-hard
so we're interested in approximation
algorithm when the graph has a general
structure we have best known
approximation ratio of the order of log
n for complete graphs I want cherry
curry Neumann proposed as early as in
2005 a randomized expected
two-point-five approximation algorithm
and the work that we are going to be
mostly interested in is the work by
cherry cherry car guru Swami and Werth
who gave a deterministic for
approximation algorithm there have been
some results very recent results from
this year that improved this constant to
2.6 but that's not going to be that
relevant for this presentation so what
is even more important and more
interesting for our setting is the fact
that you don't have to stick to the
plain vanilla description of the problem
you can also assume that the edges
rather than having a plus/minus label
also have weights and the weights are
assumed to be non-negative and you're
paying a cost let's say denoted by Omega
E + when you place this edge between
clusters so each edge misplacement has
its cost and the cost of miss placing an
edge by placing it within a cluster is
o'may are denoted by Omega E - so by
choosing those weights you can control
how much an edge is important in your
graph and how much you want to emphasize
where these this edge should belong in
the cluster structure and you can also
control in some sense the topology of
the network because basically you can
set both weights to be equal to zero for
some edges which would then imply that
that edge is completely gone from from
the graph and most of the results so far
have focused on weights that are highly
structured and so far that they satisfy
what is known as the probability
constraint so for each edge we assume
that the cost of the negative or
positive misplacement it sums up to one
and for this we know that there is an
randomized two-point-five approximation
algorithm
due to I'll on charter and human and
there are some results that tell you how
to go from unweighted problems and get
algorithms for weighted problems and the
question is given this very quick
overview of the history of the problem
do any of these methods work for the
community detection question we had in
mind in cancer genomics and the answer
is based on the observations that we had
before what do we really need for
community detection and cancer genomics
so here is an example and this is real
data from the TCGA data base or the
Cancer Genome Atlas and it lists for
something that we call a pseudo pathway
it's just an example where you have
genes indexing the vertices and you have
edges between genes to tell basically in
how many patients were both genes
simultaneously mutated so for example
this number here would say that only 2
out of 26 patient had a mutation in this
gene and this gene in the case of breast
cancer so mutual exclusivity really can
be handled in the correlation clustering
setting if you allow very high negative
weights for edges that would correspond
or capture this mutual exclusivity that
we know exists in cancer genomes or
cancer genes the idea of coverage or how
to accommodate coverage in this question
is basically through the weights of the
positive edges so you would have to
assign in a very careful manner the
weights the positive weights of the
edges in such a way that you get this
nice coverage that most patients will
have mutations within one group of genes
so that you have this x axis which
correspond to the number of patients
showing this nice coverage of all 60
patients with respect to these six
mutated genes and then in both cases we
would need some kind of way to handle
bounded cluster sizes but really what we
need is soft bounding because some
clusters can be large as long as they're
not not too many mutations in those
clusters so how do we do this
so we really couldn't apply any of the
existing algorithms because number
one none of the correlation clustering
methods are able to deal with bounded or
soft bounded cluster sizes second the
weight values that we need were not
covered by any of the solutions that
exist so we really had to redesign and
develop new algorithmic solutions that I
will discuss in the next few minutes and
then I will show you some results how we
apply these algorithms in the analysis
of breast cancer patient data so to
explain the algorithm let me just
quickly explain to you the algorithm
from which we started which is designed
for unweighted for the unweighted case
by Charlie Carr guruswami and worse and
it's a very simple two-step algorithm
the gist of the PRU the most important
aspect of this algorithm is basically to
show that it works but the algorithm
itself is pretty straight forward so we
will introduce one variable for each
edge and here we are denoting the edge
in terms of its two endpoints and one
should serve or be interpreted as saying
that those two add vertices or the edge
between them are in belong to different
clusters and there all would mean that
the end point edge vertices belong to
the same cluster so you would start with
an integer program where you're trying
to minimize the total number of
misplaced edges basically positive edges
between clusters and negative edges
within clusters and this inequality here
will basically just tell you that if you
put two edges adjacent edges in the
graph and there is a obviously a third
edge between them you would have to
complete the triangle you cannot
separate entities with these vertices in
the community so if you relax this to an
LP you get solutions which tell you
something like fuzzy clustering you will
only know if u and V are likely to be in
the same cluster or not likely to be in
the same cluster so what you need to do
is perform a second step which is the
rounding up procedure where you take the
results of the LP and recall we said
that X u W 0 means the UN W yes please
sure
the labels are assigned for you right
yes the VD trip determined the this is
right now this is cherry cherry car
guruswami worth which doesn't have
weights
yes yes yes sorry yes exactly you want
to find the communities right X you know
this here tells you which edges are
positively labeled this here tells you
which edges no xeo it tells you if they
belong to the same caste or not so if X
UV is one you should interpret it as U
and V belong to the same cluster that
edge is placed in the in one cluster it
doesn't go across clusters any other
questions okay so once you have this so
basically what you get is soft
assessments are two vertices is supposed
to be in the same cluster or not and
then you need to do some rounding up
because you're gonna get values that are
not necessarily zeros and ones so this
is what the rounding up procedure does
and it tells you if a value of u what
you should do is randomly pick an
element pick an arbitrary element and
then check what the value of its
neighbors is so if the values of the
linear programming outputs are very
small maybe you should put all those
neighbors of the selected pivoting
vertex in the same cluster or in the
same community and if when you do that
you should check that the average weight
of that community or that cluster is not
too large if it's too large you just
output a single tone if it's not too
large if it's less than or equal to T
over four then you form a community by
merging all the neighbors that you found
sufficiently close to the vertex you
picked so yes please
it's a it's a very hard bomb to get it's
actually the result is very good but
from practical point of view is it's
obviously not guaranteeing much but I
will come back to that later if I have
the time so this is the result by Chari
car guruswami inverse and I mentioned
that there were some improvements
recently but it's still 2.6 so how do we
handle the bounded cluster size and the
new weights so the bounded cluster size
we are going to handle by first
introducing a size parameter for the
clusters capital K and then we are going
to assign a special parameter for each
vertex V which is going to be non
negative movie and if this vertex here
ends up in a cluster of size that
exceeds K by this much where Y V is the
excess cluster size then we are gonna
penalize this vertex V in terms of a
cost that reads as mu V times y V if we
said all these extra penalties to zero
we don't really deal with cluster size
constraints and if we set them to be
large enough larger than the maximum
positive weight we will always get very
hard constraints basically we will
always encourage having clusters of size
less than or equal to K and this will
allow us to handle soft constraints
basically allowing some clusters to be
large if they have very few negative
edges and how do we deal with the
weights and how do we incorporate the
cluster size constraint so the weights
are very easy to put in all you need to
do is multiply each of the indicator
variables with the appropriate weights
now we have this extra term in our LP
which tells you how much do you penalize
oversized clusters this extra constraint
tells you basically how the clusters
have to be kept bounded or softly
bounded and the interesting thing is now
that you have a rounding up procedure
where you can no longer just rely on
saying that vertices should belong
together if they're let's say Sta
the distance from the LP is less than
1/2 now you have a trash hold Alfa which
will tell you when you should group
elements together with the pivot vertex
and that threshold was a 1/2 in the
original unweighted algorithm in this
algorithm it will have to depend on the
choice of the weights and on the way we
try to impose those cluster size
constraints so here are the results we
have so we have constant factor
approximation algorithms that work in
the following cases for these weights so
these are extensions of the weight
results that existed in the literature
so we basically now allow to just skip
through this because I'm running out of
time we are allowing very large values
for the negative weights which means we
can discourage two vertices being put in
the same cluster quite heavily and this
is what we really need to enforce mutual
exclusivity in a very strong way and if
you let the weights grow you basically
go back to a problem which is known as
the cluster deletion problem by Shamir
Sharan and sort which is interesting in
its own right and this is very
interesting because we couldn't get the
similar approximation bounds for nega
when we allow very large positive
weights so what we basically have to
deal with is large negative weights and
this is what we are obtained as the
results and how to choose the optimal
alpha for the rounding up procedure is
really a big mess I'll skip this but it
boils down to finding the solution for a
cubic equation and for some cases the
solution is fairly straightforward for
most of them it's a rather complicated
but it tells you that we can do
something like a uniform approximation
for the approximation ratio which Bayeux
which depends on this parameter tau
which is tied up with the choice of
alpha and the weights through this messy
equation here so let me then go ahead
and these are the approximation ratios
they're not they don't appear to be that
good at 6 or 6.2 but here are other ways
to do this you don't have to
sighs bound constraints in LP procedure
you can actually do this control of the
size of the communities in the rounding
up procedure so you just solve the LP
and if the community you get by rounding
up is too large just break it into sub
communities and there are different ways
to do this and these algorithms can also
be provably shown to give you constant
approximations and they actually work
better in practice than the previous
algorithms and since I'm running out of
time there are other ways to do this you
can do randomized algorithms similar to
this very well-known CC pivot algorithm
and it relies on using some interesting
results from edge specification as I
call it by Healthcare Patrick and Gobbo
which I can discuss with you online and
what I want to show you now is since we
have only a few minutes some of the
really interesting results that you can
get by applying the last algorithm I
talked about to benchmark data that is
available at the Cancer Genome Atlas so
the so far there were two algorithms
they try to exploit this mutual
exclusivity property for community
detection they use some integer
programming methods to try to come up
with the communities one method is
particularly well known it's called the
dendrix method and the dendrix vendek's
meso tried to impose only the mutual
exclusivity principle by performing
certain steps in the optimization
algorithm which I won't discuss right
now but what we did is we tried doing
the analysis using color correlation
clustering and we worked with data for
504 patients and this is just for breast
cancer which had a total of roughly
9,000 mutated genes and what we came up
with is some quite interesting results
so let me show you just two of them
there are many many of these pathways
that can be identified in this way this
is a set of genes in a community or in a
pathway which basically tell you very
nicely
the different forms of breast cancer
that are out there so though it's pretty
well known that your patients that have
a mutation in this gene which is quite
dominant the largest number of breast
cancer have mutations in this kinase
gene those patients would respond really
well to hormonal therapy the ones that
have mutation in cdh1 you can see that
there is very very there very few
patients based on the clustering with it
very few patients that have a mutation
in both and that very much confirms the
different type of cancer results that
are out there these patients are
so-called triple negative breast cancer
patients they have a very poor pregnant
prognosis because they don't correspond
to treatment especially hormonal
treatment so one of the goals and I'll
stop in a minute is to basically take
these algorithms and apply them to
patients before and after treatment
because what turns out to be the case is
that most cancer patients once they're
treated with one drug will develop
mutations in a different pathway and
it's really a disturbing thing because
you're treating a patient for mutations
and trying to prevent a wrong expression
in one pathway but another pathway gets
compromised so by doing before and after
community detection analysis one would
hope to see basically how the pathways
shift and I'll skip the rank a
gregarious very much related to what I
talked about so if you're interested in
talking about this online I'll be very
happy to do so
and I would like to thank you all for
being here
so what is your ETA reason that you have
N squared Internet cube constraint way
so like if you want to scale for more
than a thousand and that would probably
be a really slow so I was wondering how
does the just rounding step at work with
a few things so sort of the Green Party
no because we tried the CCP routine
figure it's it's not working well and
the one thing that I didn't mention is
you always do filtration you take genes
that are mutated in very few patients
out so you never work with the a top
boil unusually to 600-700 but it's still
a large LP is it important to get it
done in real time right now probably not
because it's more mostly exploratory
yeah so if you get to maximizers sorry
if the maximum of the relaxed version is
within let's say four times they are
relaxed version you can say something
about the Maximizer
do they overlap with you know that's all
with this how you can only say when you
apply it directly you rerun it and you
check what the how the results look like
but there is no guarantee that there is
what you're looking for you yeah and you
can vary they may be a lot of thoughts
on all solutions and they may look very
different but that's that's the problem
you have that all these problems where
you use up
summation algorithm and that's all of
BIOS sorry